rob kardashian and tyga clap back at
blac chyna after she claims she gets
zero child support from them it doesn't
stop on wednesday the model who has
children with both rob and tyga fired
off a series of tweets suggesting she
doesn't get any help financially when it
comes to raising her kids
of course she shares a nine-year-old son
king with the rapper and five-year-old
daughter dream with the reality star
your tomato
tomato
no tomato
china claims quote yesterday i had to
give up three of my cars my reasons my
morals beliefs being a single mother no
support i'm a mama single no support
child support
that tweet was reposted to a popular
instagram account where both tyga and
rob gave their two cents
in simple terms they say they're already
doing their parts as dads rob writes
quote i pay 37k a year for my daughter's
school i handle every single medical
expense i pay for all her
extracurricular activities i have my
daughter from tuesday to saturday why
would i pay child support lol
and tyga he echoed all that commenting i
pay 40k a year for my son's school and
he lives with me monday through saturday
why would i pay child support lol
and get this tyga followed up by asking
rob a question how you pay 3k less let
me know the plug with a laughing emoji
of course back in 2016 the 35 year old
arthur george founder and china starred
in their own keeping up with the
kardashians spin-off series rob in china
why do you care
so what are you trying to read who do
you think i'm texting what do you think
i'm doing but he's largely stayed out of
the limelight over the years opting to
focus on his mental and physical health
and his daughter
robert's good yeah he's working out and
eating good and so
he's on a good path right now but in a
recent interview with variety rob's
sisters courtney kim and chloe revealed
that while rob won't be on the famous
family's new reality series every week
he will make a few cameos
over the last year
we have seen such transformations from
all of us
this is day one oh my god are you dying
are you dying
and in the meantime fans are hoping to
catch more of rob on social media
earlier this month the fam shared a
sneak peek into his batman themed
birthday party complete with a
personalized batman cake and in true
kardashian fashion the karjenners gushed
over how much he means to them kim
noting that words can't describe how
special rob is chloe adding that he's
the best brother in the world while
their mom kris jenner praised her son
for growing into the most beautiful soul
the best father ever the most amazing
brother uncle grandson and friend
[Music]
you